I've always had a confident confidence
in my body an unfounded confidence but I
don't know why so where are you insecure
then where don't you have because when I
was one I wanted to ask I mean you go
topless for the rest of this episode
right okay for sure you want me to take
it pop the top off
my
oh
what would you say I don't have
confidence
like you looking at me and you're like
you know what I'm a bald big nose found
piece of yeah yeah and I love them
and I love them I love every ounce of
them I love every way down to this guy
look at you you look you look a Greek
god next to me so I like being the low
the barrier yes eventually why do you
like that because I think I like to make
people feel good about themselves
because I feel like
I get it I'm fat doing this on purpose
so disgusting you look like this you
look like this for you